FINANCIACHAIWOMAMAXINE
WARS, AT SHE JT ANNOUNCE
BUT FIRST, STOLEN INNOCENCE,
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TOGHT'
ANGLE.
NOW, I STI REMBER WHENY DAUGHTE
FIVE OR SIX,HE WANTEAN
ERIC GIRL DOLL FOR
RISTS.
I WENT AND OKEDT EM.
FELL FORHEENED BRA'S RLLY
WHOLESOME KI OPATRIOTIC
RKETG AND I MADE SURE NTA
PUT ONUNDETHE EE THAYEAR
COMPLETEITH FEW TFIT
CHANGEAND EACH VERSI OF THE
DOLLAD ITS OWN STORYBOOK THAT
ACMPANIED IT.
WELLMOMS ACRS ERICA,
BEFORE YOU TNK OSHELLING OUT
WH IS IT OVER A HUNDRED BUS
R A MADE IN AMERICLLWELLFOLITTL
KN A F THIFIRS
TTEL MANUFACRETHEM
CHA.
AY?
SECO, THTOY MAKER IS NOW
USING S BRANTOROMOTE
TRANSGENDERISMO LITTLEIDS.
ITS STORY BOOKS DISCUSS HOW TO
LAY PUBERTY WI HORMONE
BLKERSND INSTRUCTS ON WAYS
TO KP INFORMATION OM
PARENTS.
NOW, C YOUELIEVE THIS IS
WHERWE ARE IN CIETWHERE
THE'S SUCH A THING AS LL
PROPAGANDA?
NOW, MATTEL ISN'T EVRYING
BE STLE OUITS AGEN.
AIN,HE DOLS INSTRUCTION BOOK TE
FE LIKGIRLS INSIDE, WHICH
EY SAY IS TALLOKAY
AND IT IRODUCES E NCEPTS
BEI N-BINY, AIN
TTLE KID AND USINGALTERNATE PRO.
BUT, LOOK, W SHOULD ANY OF US
BE SURPRISED?
THE GENDER FLUIDY MOMENT MAY
HAVE SRTED ON COEGE CAMPUSESYEA
FILTTED ERY ASPE
CORPATE ERICA AND R PUIC
SCHOS.
RANS ELOYE, EY CHE
XES AND G LANDNDRANS
APICANTS GET THETTENTION OF
COLLEGE ADMIIONS OFFICERS.AND,
TERTAINMENT INSTRY THEY'
BEENN BOARD WITH THIS FOR
YES.
ANPLOT LE TEPLOT LE
YOSEE PROMOT CHARACTER
BRELY REBELLING AINSSTUFFY
OLD NORMS  DECRING THEJUSTDON'T
THEIBIOLICAL SEX.
>> I FL MO MELF IN BOY'S
CLOTHES.
ACTUALLY, DA I D'T THINK I'M
GIRL AAL
>> SUZ.
>> EVETHOU Y'VE ALWAYS
THOUGHOF ME AS A GIRL, I A
BOY.
>> Lra: D ACNG, D PL.
AN ENTE COAGE INDUST OF
TRANS HEALTHCAREXPER ALSO
HAS BEEN CREATED TO CONDUCT
WORKSHOPS D GET PAID
HASOMELY FOR IT D THEY DO IT
R BUNESS SCARED OF
LAWSTS.
ANTHEN THERE WELCOMED AS
SPEARS APRESTIGIOUS MEDICA
CONFERENCE
ENTEDR. MASSA LADINSKI.
ANSSOCTE PROSSOR AT E
IVERSITY OF ALABAMA BERG HAM.
SHE'DESCBED ON THE SCHL'S
B SI AS HAVING A I REARCH
TERE IPROVIDING AFRMING
CARE TO BTQ YOUTAND
IDENFIED WITH FAMILIES IN THE D
FAITH-SED MMUNITIES THER
IN THE DP SOUTH, THINGS ARE
OBVIOUSLY REAL BAD.
NOW,T THE ACEMY OF PEDIATRI CONO
CALIRNIAECENTLY, SHE SPO
CLOG ABOUT TRANSDEOLOGY AND,
MORE DISTURBINY, AUT THE
LD SUICIDE OA TRGI
>>ND IN THE FINAL DAYS OF
14, A LOCAL 16 YR OLD YOG LADY D
BOLDLY IFRONT OF A TRACK FOR
TRAILER ENDER R LIFE.
HER SUICIDNO, WRITN POST ON CIAT
UR AFTERER DTH, NT
VIRA LITERALLY, AROUND THE
RLD.
>> Laura: THIS WOM IS A TOL
WHACJOB AND ON THE W PATH
AINST TRADITIOL AMICANS.
W,EMEMBER, RELIOUS
AMERICS ARTHE PROBLEM.
TRANS PIONEERS, WELL, TH'RE
THE ANER.
COURSE,HE AAPOESN'T MAK
ITS VIDEOS PUBC.HMM, WONDER WHY
THOUGH, WIHE INSANITY BEING
STAMLINED BY THE
ADMINISTRAON OF THPRACTICING
CATHOLIC JOEIDEN.
>>E HAVE REACHEDIPPING
POINT R THE ROLE IN FE FOR
THE HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF
LGBTPLUS YOUTH AND YOUNG
AMERICANS.
I ENCOURAGALL OFOU TO TO
THK OF YOURSELVES AS AM SS TOURE
ESE CONVERSAONS DON'T HAVE
BE LIMITED  RESTRICTETO A
SETTINBUT R PRINCEICAL
SCHOOL TEAERS HOOL BOARDS.
>> Lau: LO ONLKNOWS HOW
MANY PEDTRICIANS VEMEN
SAGREE WITH THE OBSCE
PLANS TO STE OURHILDREN'S INNOCC
I BET THE MAJOTY SEE T
BUHERI IS EVIL PURE D SIMPLE B
THE AMICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIRICS
>>HEY VE NO EA HOW Y
IDENTIFY WHI KIDS ARE TRAN
ANREQUIRE TREAENT.
TH'RE LIKEE'RE JUST
CHNICIANS AND WE'LL ST TEL
U IF YOU HE TRANS KID
'LL LL YOU H TO DOHE
TRANTION.
AND THEN THE AMERICAN ACEMOF
PEATRICS THE NEXT AR LPT
IN THAVOID ANDAID, O
WE'LL TELL YOU HOW YOUNOW
ICH KIDS.
YOU K EM.AND IF TY SAY EY'RE TR
THEN THEY'RE TRANS.
>> Laura: ERE NEEDS TO BA
SSIVE ASS TION LAWSUIT
AGNST P.
THDIRECTORF BOSTON GENAL'S
GEER CLINIC WITTINGLY
REALS THEIR DIY LITTLE
SECRET ABO THESETRONG DRUG
DOPLAYED APUBERTOCKERS.
>> I WORRYHATHEY'RBEING
GIVEOUA LOT LIKE CAN WHI
ISREATN SOME WAYS BUT IT'S
ALSO LIKE, OKAY,ELL WYOU KNO
YOU ED TO VE THE
NVERTION.
>>auraSHE SAYS GREN SO
WAYS.
'S NOT LIKE THEYLIFECHANGING RA
TH THESE DRUGSR ANYTHI,
NO.
I MEONCE YOUNCOURAGE
TRSITIING AT ANY AGE, THE
ISO GUARANTEE THAT YOU CEVER REE
SCALAMAGE DONE TO YOURSELF.>> I
THING VE EVER GONE THRGH IN
MY LIFE.IN ADDITN TOHE HLTH SID
EFFECTS I EXPERICETHE WAY IT
FECTED MY CARE AS A NGER HAS BE
DE WITH.
MY SINGINGND SPEAKINVOICE
WI NEVER BE THE SAME AFTER MY
TIME ON TESTOSTENE.
>> Lra: BUT THESE UGS E
GRT FOKIDSATEASTHAT'S
WHAT ANOTHAPXECUTIVE
COMMTEE MEMBER SAYS.
PUBERTYLOCKERS N BE SUCH
A GREAT MECINE FORIDS WH
E STARTING PUBERTY.PARENTS MAORB
ACCEPTING, TS MABE A
SURPRI TO THE RENT.
IT JT SLS THINGS DOWN.
TH'RE VERYAFE AND FECTE.
TH THEEXT OPTI IS GEND
AFFIRMING HORME THERAPY.>> Laur
HERE.
CHILDREN A THE TAR
RKET, AND THE POORIDS ARE
LLING TO THE TRAP.
>> I USED TO FL WHEN I FIRST
TOLD YOU I W A GL.
>>IXTH GRADE IS SUCH A HD
YEAR ANYY R EVERYONE ESPECIAL WS
>>ACK WH I W IN EITH
GRE OVER WINR EAK, TT'
EN FST WAS EXPED T I
GUESTHE RD TRAGEND, AND
JUST, LIKE AS I WAS READG
ABOUIT, I ST FELT LIKELIKE
AT WAS ME.
Laura: THISS AN AGGREIVE
RKETG PUSH COAST TO COAST.EXCEP
WHCOURAGEOUS GOVNORS L
RON DeSANT AREUCCESSFULLY
FIGHTI THIATTACK ON INNOCENCTHES
WILL CONTINUE.
LEFT IN ITS WAKETHOUGH,
COUROUR CHILDREN'S
NOCEE, GROOMING TH FORHENEW BAT.
THFACTHAPROFESSIONAL
ORNIZAONS, SUCH AS THE AMA
ANTHE AMERICAN AOCIAON OF
PEDIRICS HAVE BEEN SUBVERTED
BY THE POLITIC ANDEXUAL
IDEOLOGY HE IS TERRIBLE FOR THED
REPUTION OF THE BLIC HEALT
SECT.
THOU THE PEDTRICS
SOCIATION CLAI TO  WKING
FOR THE HEALTH BENITS  ALLCHILD
MBERS ON ITS LGBT HEALTH AND
WELLNESS COMMITTEE ENDORSE
PUBEY BLKERS FORATIEAS
YOUNG AS TENS OSS SEX
HORMONES TO PATIENTS AYOUNAS
14.
THIS IS ABLUTE APPALNG A
IT FRANKLY SATAN CAN.
YOU WANT TO KW THE UTH BREADTH
RECOMMEND YOREAD AAR'S ENTIRE P.
THINNOCENCE AND WONDERME
WI CONNUE AND WE MUSNEVE
EVERLLOW OURSEES TO
TIMITED BY ALL THO PEOPLE
WITH TITLES ANTHEIR VANCED
DEGRS OROVERNMENT SITIONS.
TER L LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID
WITHOVID.
THE LIESTHE COSUPS AND
CASHING A SASS NATNS